à pékin les autorités chinoises ont fait
savoir qu'elles étudiée très
soigneusement les conséquences de cette
catastrophe nucléaire tandis qu'à
washington on attend la réponse de la
proposition d'être faite aux soviétiques
réponse est non encore reçu ici nous
trouvons à saint laurent des eaux dans
la partie où l'on fait les contrôles de
pollution atmosphérique et contrôle de
radiation nous allons essayer de voir
avec jacques fiolet comment se passe
tous ses contrôles en france pour les 16
centrales je vous rappelle pour
l'éventuel pollution nous allons voir
avec un reportage à l'institut de
protection contre les rayonnements
ionisants au vésinet près de paris
aucune mesure particulière en france le
centre de protection contre les
rayonnements continue son travail de
fourmi travail de surveillance et de
contrôle dans cette salle par exemple
arrivent tous les jours des échantillons
d'eau provenant de toutes les
installations nucléaires françaises
des prélèvements effectués en contenus
dans les rivières de la même façon sur
tout le territoire français
130 stations effectué des prélèvements
quotidiens que ce soit sur des poissons
le lait des vaches les cultures l'eau de
pluie ou les poussières atmosphériques
tous ces prélèvements sont analysés
contrôler et comptabilisés dans cette
salle unique au monde pour vérifier le
niveau de la pollution de
l'environnement
en plus de ces contrôles très stricts
plus de cinquante mille par an le
service de protection assurent la
sécurité des personnes dans le cas où un
accident comme celui de tchernobyl se
produiraient les mesures simples dans un
premier temps on demande simplement aux
gens de rester chez eux
portes et fenêtres fermées le temps du
passage du panache pour l'instant il n'y
a aucun risque avec l'accident qui vient
d'avoir lieu en union soviétique
ah ça je peux vous dire qu'en france il
n'y a absolument aucun risque on pourra
certainement détecté dans quelques jours
le passage
des particules mais au du point de vue
de la santé publique il n'y a aucun
risque
tous les résultats de ces prélèvements
sont ensuite analysés par de puissants
ordinateurs comparer publié est envoyé à
tous les organismes étrangers similaires
dans le monde alors toutes les infos